so since the anime man you're coming on
the podcast today
our first time is this your first time
yes
I thought so we've got like some actual
like interesting questions I feel from
the VIP sections of like our tour you
know so to explain uh in every show we
do we had like an hour kind of like VIP
q a and sometimes you can kind of expect
what questions would be asked I think we
had a bet on in the Germany show about
uh how many questions it would take to
ask me about my opinions on bread
because every single show came up yeah
yeah uh but I think I feel like one
interesting question we actually got was
someone actually asked uh what are the
seven wonders of anime and then we
started answering it and then we
realized that uh we should probably stop
because we were getting into an argument
about it and we had we had a show to do
the next day everybody showed you the
next hour sorry so we were just like
yeah but yeah are we counting in manga
and this was strictly anime oh
you don't read mangakona so yeah but why
would that play why would that play okay
why would I play into your you you you
[__] a dramatic pause to call me out
you're like
you're dumb
why would it would it affect your eyes
oh absolutely because like if we're
talking if we're including market like
berserk is up there but if it's not it's
it's oh that is sure
to clarify that right now for the
audience so they're like why wasn't this
thing on there it's like because okay
here's here's the thing I've always
noticed about the difference between
give me a yes or a no oh God okay the
answer is no okay okay have you noticed
this about like the manga Community
where no one can agree on what the best
anime is but in terms of like the golden
mangas it's always [__] Vagabond
berserk okay
slam dunk you know it's always like the
same 10 manga they get I guess mentioned
I'm not sure I'm glad that we got that
out of the way right now yeah so no
longer just strictly and number one hit
me up all right my hero actually shut
the [__] up Connor shut the [__] up
because nothing has United people in
hating so much you know I just think
that I thought it was the Dragon Ball
fans for the longest time can we get
this clear first and foremost like what
are the like the credentials for it to
be considered like the Seven Wonders
like does it have to be like okay
actually going Beyond anime what are the
actual seven wonders of the world can
you guys can you guys name the seven
wonders of the world well one of them is
the pyramids I'm getting that one right
now
Stonehenge I don't know
that is not a [__] one [__] off okay
Great Wall of China troll of course this
is more than seven yeah that's that's
definitely more than seven the new Seven
Wonders oh yeah there's like the old
seven wonders of the world and the new
seven one yes sir the whole Seven
Wonders is [__] dumb right yeah I
prefer Mount Rushmore as an allegory
because very it's a lot more intense you
see Facebook as a wonder what yeah it's
like a as like a description like
obviously there's a foreign
actually Mount Rushville is the best one
though I mean I mean I won't say Matt
Russell is very impressive how the [__]
did they build that you know if you're
gonna do that now we'd be like sorry
guys I know the hidden Leaf Village did
it kind of better you know yeah
okay when we say Seven Wonders what we
mean is like just the seven most
greatest or influential yeah we've got
to get the definition clear right like
are we talking about like seven like you
know influential anime
commercially viable because each of the
wonders in our real world they all do
something different so I think an anime
could be up there for being influential
but anime could also be up there for
just being the like yeah and maybe one
of them is uh has done something or
inspired yeah I mean we just searched up
Seven Wonders
not not none of you not even the the
internet can figure out what a wonder is
so I guess we just go by there's an
anime News Network with seven wonders of
anime
of the anime world
yeah they actually just
maybe controversial opinion I don't
think Astro Boy should be on there yes
it [__] Joey come on come on come on
yes yes I am serious I need to hear your
reasoning though I mean yeah kind of
like it's like it's like being like Oh
yeah oh top 10 film is Citizen Kane
number two it's like okay
okay we get it we're not talking about
that we want something excited yeah no
no one gets like I'm excited not every
wonder of the world is exciting yes they
are yes
the point of the Seven Wonders of the
World at least like my kind of personal
definition is like it's on everyone's
like bucket list right or places you
need to see uh before before you kick
the bucket right you don't need to see
it you don't need to see Astro Boy Yes
it started anime
who's [__] watch Astro Boy Joey who
shut the [__] up Joey
I've read the mongers get the [__] out
because I'm a real anime fan okay I I
just think that it's kind of it feels
like a cop-out to put it on the list
yeah
because it's such a we're doing a
podcast here it's gonna be entertaining
and I feel like it's boring okay let's
just [__] add my hero Academia then
how about let's add it how about that
dude all my
sexy yes
you want skinny version or you want
buffers yeah you can get either the
stuff that uh Endeavor has done for
Daddy Issues change the game like that's
they progressed they've been arrested
okay proves that Daddy issue is not a
gender specific yeah you know yeah very
very Progressive guys
yeah I just think that if we put Astro
Boy it's kind of you know okay fine
let's not put Astro Boy then would you
put Astro Boy on abso [__] lutely
because if we wouldn't be [__] but
then we're gonna have a list that's like
every old thing not necessarily I think
Astro Boy is the only like old school
anime that I would include on the Seven
Wonders personally [__] off
personally okay okay let's let's decide
right now we'll go we're only gonna
agree to one old anime
okay what's what's your definition of
all like before the 90s before the 90s
80s 70s 60s right yeah okay if there was
one what would you pick probably
something probably it's probably got to
be like mobile sugandam right like I
guess we could put multiple Gundam
Gundams up there I mean Gundam Gundam is
still I came to this day that has like
its lineage has gone like you know since
the beginning Gundam and it still goes
on to this day okay are we including
movies
if that's the case then I agree with
Connor I think Akira should be up there
even though I know you don't write it
okay let's let's put it on the maybe
list okay let's see if we can think of
uh like you know I agree with is there
something we all agree on I agree with
you on Gundam okay uh one one I would
like so the first thing that absolutely
comes to mind for me yeah is Evangelion
Evangelion I think is the very
definition of the anime that's you know
like I should have put Gundam on sorry
I'd rather put Gundam on I feel like
Gundam makes more sense what is gonna
make more sense uh Evangelion is just
sad Gundam right more depressed I can't
believe you just said it's like it's
listen it's just listen listen Gundam is
if we're talking influential it's pretty
like the most in terms of and I'm happy
to agree with that no man uh if it
wasn't for mazinga Zed uh Gundam
wouldn't be here so yeah but how many
seasons does mazingazette have it's like
two I think yeah so I mean I I feel like
Gundam has way more I think is always
also has a lineage that goes on to I
think yeah but I feel like we've got to
talk like pop culture relevance as well
and if we're talking that um I mean look
at how many fighters like in in terms of
Pop Culture reference in Japan I would
argue Ava is [__] up there I mean it
to me it's like the influence is had on
kind of like merchandising right because
that's just that's just because the Ava
team was just like they understood
marketing right Gundam Gundam was like
okay you know we'll make the gunplas and
those are still like those huge [__]
like yeah but with Ava it was like let's
put all of our characters on [__]
yeah that's because of the marketing
team not because of the anime I don't
[__] watch the single gun right I
just Evangelion is super popular only
really in Japan to that level whereas
Gundam is globally known on such a more
wider scale and also I feel good
own amongst like different generational
like groups you know also like this
might be a hot take but I think it's
more important that an anime fan watches
Ava than an anime fan watches Gundam and
I know I've probably pissed off all the
gundam fans I mean I think that's fair I
think I think Ava is just such it's it's
like such a turning point for like the
anime kind of like industry as a whole
um you don't need to like Ava but I feel
like everyone needs to experience it at
least once just to have an opinion on it
there's a reason why Ava aired and
[__] I think 1995 or 1997 I can't
remember the exact year and it's like
been over 20 years and we are still
discussing it you know okay yeah let's
get a good idea then because so we we
have a Google search of top 10 most
influential anime pulled up so let's see
what Google says is the top 10 and then
we can kind of go from there number one
is Akira okay all right it is not the
number one most influential
yeah
number one okay what's number two
thank you oh my god wow influential is a
an important term yeah yeah all right
what's number three
[Music]
all right number four
Pokemon
[Music]
um
the game yes I would I wouldn't
necessarily say the anime it's hard to
it's hard to like boil Pokemon down to
its anime because it's just like a
[__] multimedia franchise yeah it's
kind of been stuck in like the Saturday
car Saturday morning cartoon Loop yeah
it's kind of like it's kind of like
putting Hello Kitty on there you know
like is it influential is it iconic yes
but is it something that deserves to be
on a list like this I'm not sure all
right number five number five
wow yeah okay it is my favorite Julie
film but I personally wouldn't put it on
there this is just like dude this is the
most generic ass safe left ever yeah
yeah go down all right number six
okay okay there we go
even I don't know how much money does
Gundam make a year of selling Gundam
kits it must be like like a stupid half
of the Japanese economy I mean I think I
think gundam model kits make more money
than the Dragon Ball franchise
absolutely yeah I wouldn't be surprised
by that yeah I'm not surprised one thing
I find interesting as I swear I know
more people that are into model kits and
just have only seen like one gun okay or
are not even a gun okay okay
131.3 billion yen in sales over the past
year yeah so basically one billion
dollars here's what I'm thinking guys I
think we need to separate this into
genres because I think we need like the
Mount Rushmore or the genre up here okay
so I feel like we're Gundam we're
calling it The Mecca one right you know
what I mean well the remaining ones were
Sailor Moon and Evangelion okay oh okay
I mean yeah I mean I understand
Evangelion uh I I think Gundam is more
influential but I guess it's up to us
what we decided yeah uh all right all
right all right guys guys all right hear
me out hear me out okay because Dragon
Ball we've already we've just all said
the dragon balls up there right okay